(mysterious music)
- [Leslie Voiceover]
I've always been drawn
to abandoned and forgotten places.
(camera shutter clicks)
(mysterious music)
Behind every door there's a story.
(camera shutter clicks)
(mysterious music)
Every room and every object
has something to say.
(camera shutter clicks)
(mysterious music)
You never know what you’re going to find
or who you'll find.
(mysterious music)
My name is Leslie Muir.
I photograph and explore abandoned places
in Ontario, Canada.
(camera shutter clicks)
(mysterious music)
(light music)
Any time I go to an abandoned house
there's still an energy, there's
still a story to be told.
You can feel it from the
time you step out of your car
on that driveway,
and that's the beauty of it,
the beauty is the unknown.
(mysterious music)
About a year ago I was driving home,
had seen this house a million times,
never thought to stop, it was just
another abandoned house.
For some reason I did a U-turn
in the middle of the road,
and I got out of my car
and started taking pictures
of the outside.
When I went inside it was
still an abandoned house to me.
It was dark, there was stuff everywhere,
any sign that you saw would
have led you to believe
that nobody had lived there,
it was an abandoned home.
I heard a radio and a timid
hello from the corner,
and I met Lawrence.
(camera shutter clicks)
(anxious piano music)
He looked tired, he looked lonely.
He had a fractured hip.
He was missing one eye.
He was in a pretty rough shape.
I thought, "Here's your chance
"to be there for somebody who needs it."
(inspiring piano music)
It started with some visits,
getting to know each other,
and now we're genuinely friends.
(camera shutter clicks)
- [Leslie Voiceover] It's
really hard to find somebody
that you can genuinely
trust in this world,
somebody who is not gonna judge you.
He has made me realize
what's really important.
(melancholic piano music)
- [Leslie Voiceover] People takes pictures
of what they care about,
of what they're proud of,
of what they want to remember.
Nobody takes a picture of something
that they want to forget.
So, I try to take his picture
as often as possible now.
(camera shutter clicks)
(melancholic piano music)